- all right guys that's it well - mine
[Music]
so I gonna break anyway yeah you know
Jake's only been in Texas a few weeks
now but yeah this is really it's coming
in so we'll try and I guess translate
for you guys what Jake is actually
saying it's true with every passing week
a song it's a little bit longer one we
get to release a novelty podcast that
just an hour
banjo kind kind of okay and a banjo make
is that max all I'm saying it's just a
little laptop it's cuz he's all the way
over in Texas dude yeah yeah holler
thank you for real you know what should
we adjust this and start over this works
we can hear you let's keep on we just
have to pay attention to when Jake
speaks and I'll respectfully go silent
and listen yes speaking can you hear me
I can hear you I I just hear slurping
people got to listen to us Tecna
technically troubleshoot the podcast for
the first minute yeah we start over no
no this is this is a great introduction
which is which is the day we talk about
Adobe and their software and you're like
wow that sounds boring I'm out I'm like
wait don't leave wait don't leave I'm
I'm out of conversation about lesser
imps and demons anyway come into your
hardware and your software and your life
and really mess things up but for real
what this is really a conversation about
is the one of the backbones of what we
make like the tools that we use and well
a video came out a few days ago from an
animator
I was named James Lee and it's him
complaining about Adobe products and but
it's animated it's animated with Adobe
product ooh with Adobe products mm-hmm
but the thing is it's coming at where
this moment we're like more and more
people are complaining orally
being Adobe's software bundle and you
know as something that's been like part
of our lives honestly for like you know
15 20 years at this point I think it's
worth reflecting a little bit on this
and like cuz there's some drama here
there's some stories there's some things
that like have affected our livelihoods
and some expectations for for big media
product to to follow through and so
these promises that they perhaps haven't
been in like any tool of any trade you
know you have certain ones that are like
fundamental and as digital filmmaking
has gotten bigger and bigger and people
have started to utilize the techniques
that we've been messing around with for
years this tool in particular has become
more and more a part of everything you
see yeah yeah there's not a lot of
competition out there either it's kind
of like if I was like you know named
popular web browsers you'd be like
Chrome Firefox Internet Explorer Safari
like and that's kind of it the same
thing with like named popular video
editing programs like premiere I don't
final kind of go you're forgetting avid
media composer everyone uses avid media
composer right across this great really
nice because you can actually tell us in
your digital footage in the film to edit
manually to give you one of those beige
track balls from mega to the magic orb
so things like talking about Adobe's
gonna be I don't say tricky but it'll be
kind of tricky because we actually have
a really good relationship with Adobe
like we speak for them at NAB so my hope
is that in this podcast or we're going
to talk about Adobe's problems ideally
it's in a way that like Adobe themselves
could listen to it I'm back you know
what valid points
this is constructive like I don't this
just be a complaint fest I want this to
be more of a reflection on like what our
expectations are for like these tools
that we use and how they have been
is down at times or you know in what
cases have they not have what cases that
they've been a bastion of you know
innovation after-effects is perfect
couldn't be better
After Effects is still slow and you're
just moving the image around yeah what
I'm trying to do FFX is perfect so we
can just take that one set it aside
linked comps do you guys still do that
no and do you still have to reverse your
yes compound that is like the epitome of
Dobby yeah right there give you this
note me you left the a off oh oh of
course worse we actually are we talking
I remember with us we have have you do
you know the story of Dobby
oh man the story at the tail of Dobby
well we had a lot of we mentioned in our
last in last vlog Jake you were
mentioning Dobby a lot and a lot of our
new audience members were like who's
this Nobby guy you guys keep Rocking
yeah that's why we wanted to talk about
this in addition to the things that Nico
mentioned but we realized it's been oh
probably 18 months since we've actually
told the audience where Dobby is and so
Nick take it away man okay I guess I'm
taken away so Dobby I believe that the
year was 2017 and you had just won these
heavy metals banging on your chest just
clinking around everyone in Nashville
knew they heard me clinking around yes
chat they can hear you in national yeah
they could hear me and I heard that the
clinks that was a that was such a weird
funny trip one of the things to come out
from that 10 gig tournament hold on we
should talk about 10 giggles so we went
out there for a pub G tournament we did
this pub G tournament with shonduras and
dominated yeah we and uh afterwards we
were you know grabbed we decided let's
grab a few brews grab some drinks at
this little uh
that was like empty it was like pool
hall right it was an Irish pool hall
thing very cool really great beautiful
lacquered wood
you know there's balconies this was
somewhere it felt kind of like it was
like a little bit of a medieval tavern
kind of live in their classic pub you
could see like a Western like bar fight
gone down there to like guys getting
like thrown from the balconies and stuff
or more like a English fight with top
hats and canes and yeah yeah what is it
what are those sticks that they carry
around so I think this was we just been
actually having our own troubles with
Adobe back at the studio it was fresh on
our minds it's fresh in our minds
someone I think was like really really
getting into the pool oh yeah we're
taking that pool cue oh that's so hard
grounders and these balls were
uncontrollable and of course when you're
gonna take a shot we're gonna take a
dunk a shot a lob what do you say in
real life you say Kobe Kobe Kobe rest in
peace but when you're gonna take a janky
shot so you say the word and somehow in
that pool game after like I think it was
you who's hittin those fly balls I think
we all remember it was like a shared
experience yeah someone just yells Dobby
just built on itself and we so see it at
that moment a feeling of utter like
failure and chaos tank you know but
whimsy
there's whimsy and whimsy you know and
suddenly that feeling was associated
with this word Dobby and little did we
know that by speaking his name he would
follow us all the way home I think it
was saying he was like this little Dobby
guy just picked up my pool ball and
carried it over
high velocity so out of that experience
and all those straight pool balls we
kind of I guess drew the line drew the
connection to Adobe and Dobby being a a
demon of jank thought of Jake maybe
because Adobe products have been filled
with jinx his time in memorium and you
just Yuri v8 it you take the little a
off the front yeah no it was almost a
coincidence though that it it turned
into that whole Adobe thing a
coincidence only we weren't in the fact
that it was a subconscious connection
yeah like it wasn't a meet it wasn't
like we're talking about Adobe and
really honest janky Dobby but but but
that's how you know it's real because it
was so subconscious and like the Adobe
jank was so embedded in our in our
psyches and our hearts that we just
automatically drew the connection and
and it was born that day and then I
believe Sam was like Dobby probably has
a little sharpener pool cue that he like
snapped off yeah just Dragonball Z we
just ripped that one straight from very
ballsy ya homes your computer in the GPU
and it coaches it out yeah he gets that
broken cue stick and he just something
breaks because there's no way that when
you're paying $50 a month over the
course of years that the product itself
wouldn't function right so it's got to
be something else
all religions I feel like are like put
in place too as an explanation it's like
a explain exactly for the unexplainable
so this was our answer to that like as
in I hit spacebar in my video stop
playing why did it stop I don't know
it's opposite day I'm not getting any
you know informative error codes from
this program so it must be dobby the god
well you're like I'm gonna go export and
you hit like control or control em and
there's just like nothing happens and
you're like huh so you go to the menu
and a hit board from there and say that
work why did it work I don't know I
don't know you spend a week working on a
project and
time to export it so you know you're
converting it to an mp4 and h.264 if you
will and it's Friday evening you can't
wait to go home theaters waiting for you
and then it just stops and says export
failure halfway through yeah who knows
or if you if you import your footage
without saying a little prayer at the
end of the project right before you hit
export everything the whole sequence
gets corrupted and you can't replace
anything and you have to legitimately
re-edit the entire video from scratch oh
man
anyways we were talking we were telling
tales of our experiences here with Adobe
Premiere so for those of you guys who
don't use Adobe products Adobe has a
subscription model where you pay fifty
dollars now fifty three dollars a month
to have access to their products and you
know with that is supposed to come this
idea of constant updates and you know
the the program stays current with
things like you know you can use any
camera with the DOE because they're
always updating it to include the new
codecs except for the Blackmagic codec
which they won't put in the program
probably because Blackmagic is a direct
competitor and now they're putting you
know their business competition beyond
the experience of the users anyway this
is one of the many complaints you're
going to hear from us magic did release
a simple download though that it solves
for premiere but it doesn't work in
after-effects right so Blackmagic
themselves went out of the way to fix it
because Adobe wasn't doing it even
though it's one of the most highly
requested features on their feature
request board but this is you know this
is one of many examples like for example
the MKV format it's an open source video
codec if you're using like OBS which is
like a screen capture software you can
capture it into an MKV format one of the
nice things is is if your computer
crashes and recording an MKV it actually
the file still works it doesn't just
corrupt the whole file so useful formats
been around forever it's open source and
they removed MKV support from Premiere
so there's all these kind of like little
weird decisions that come into play not
to mention like user experience and it'd
be one thing if you paid 10 bucks a
month for the program or if you know you
bought it two years ago and then
obviously it hasn't been updated you're
waiting for the next big update
but when you're paying over $50 a month
and if you have mostly yeah $50 a month
six under bucks a year and by the way we
probably pay for what like four five six
state six accounts at least six now you
know like in those fantasy movies where
you see a wizard draining it like
lifeforce and you see like energy like
being sucked out of your body
yeah the DPS from Adobe and adobe has
one of those trained in our studio and
you can see these green dollar signs
just kind of like floating out of the
studio at all times
I remember when we got when we got them
to give us accounts way back yeah and we
were like oh [ __ ] we could we got free
Adobe accounts no dude I got some free
drugs man Final Cut yeah yeah yeah I
mean I think all editors who were using
Final Cut 7 when Final Cut 10 came out
they were like we need something else
and Adobe was over there with their
little timeline that looked just like
seven computers they even had all the
key cuts or key shortcuts already
programmed in you could just switch at
Final Cut 7 so that was nice props Dobby
that was nice and and then we all
discovered that every time they had a
major release they didn't bug tested
extremely thoroughly and you ended up
with a professional piece of software
that causes you to act actively lose
money because you updated to the newest
release instead of waiting a month or
two you for yeah so first Patrick to
Nico you're you're one of the most
staunch defenders of this this
philosophy that I don't hear a lot which
is never update what is that about so
you know updating when something this is
the thing that like I've actually kind
of really grown to dislike about modern
computing you have a program that works
when you update it you risk breaking it
you know the whole thing you know if it
if it works or if it ain't broken don't
fix it you know that applies you
frequently to the tools that you need to
do for your like for your job and Adobe
constantly releases updates with the
idea that
those new features new codec there's a
new you know thing to support are they
optimized you know this for running on
this hardware etc so you do these
updates but very frequently something
breaks when you update and it's usually
not like the new feature that breaks
it's usually just some old reliable
feature that now suddenly is just broken
and it sometimes seems nonsensical and
it's one of those frustrating things
where you expect this stuff to be
thoroughly vetted or at least if they're
going to do a major update you expect
them to realize that they're their
clients are almost more interested in a
program that's stable and doesn't crash
then they are in having like some
brand-new like titles feature like we
figured out titles a long time ago yes
it would be nice to have like an instant
link to like a good title generator
don't get me wrong like that's what
Apple does really well but before we get
to like what's I consider you know like
those frosting roses on a birthday cake
like the actual dough of the birthday
cake needs to not have like pieces of
glass in it it's like I hit export on
this timeline in a crashes halfway
through and I have no error code to
figure it out or you know which is just
not even crash to begin with because it
plays like if there's all these little
things probably cuz the programs like 25
years old at this point or some like
that and just it's been built and built
and built in layers on itself and they
haven't really gone back and just
cleaned it you know but that they won't
be able introduce new features in noise
bullet points they can market to is hey
it's more stable but I think they're not
recognizing that that's actively what a
lot of the users want from this program
because we're just editing videos at the
end of the day we've been able to edit
videos for years and years and years I
just want to be able to do it smoothly
quickly and reliably and anytime that
doesn't happen like we are losing money
and you're getting stressed I have an
example that that this happened last
summer when the effects artists react
was like it it's probably like when we
first started releasing it and it was
like we got to get one out every week we
still do mm-hmm
but there were a lot of late nights and
you guys have all heard of Chanukah
right the eight nights of Hanukkah
yeah yeah so you know the oil burned for
a
it's and that's it's set down in history
well don't we
it was about 10:00 p.m. and just
finished the Edit on VFX artist react
like just eyes are bloodshot and just
like ready to go home and Dobby decides
to flutter down and hit export and
instead of eight nights of oil in the
lamp it's eight nights of eight days oh
my god
so and that was just for rendering the
audio files we didn't even get through
the auto audio files to the video so
randomly for no explicable reason there
was no error code it just gave us it was
I think me and Carmichael are still
doing that it's and we just we were
there to like three o'clock and we
eventually had to literally screen cap
the dang export we'd made before and
then export just our audio from Adobe
and then sync that up in a separate new
project it was just oh man dude we had
to do that even more recently on a note
video we had to do a lot of things he
had the same issue and he had to scream
cat he was able to export the audio but
then he had to screencap the video like
the playback like it would playback in
the program if he had spacebar full
screen in the in the video cap screen
capping at 1080 yeah we had to do that
multiple times we also had to do that
for uh I was like the top ten breaching
techniques or whatever yeah that video
we had to just rate up full screen turn
on shadow play hit hit play in Premiere
because then one export but it would
play back at full quality without any
issue
it's just right so the other day the
other day I was trying to get a just a
video up on so that a client could look
at it and I brought it I saved all the
project folders on my external drive I
took it from Texas to LA I plugged it in
I had a
and the most recent version of dobby on
both both computers I open up the
project everything links everything's
fine
I go to export it and I get some weird
export failure and I was I was up until
like 1:00 a.m. searching the internet
and and across the YouTube videos and
they were like kids on there being like
hey hey you got this problem ok yeah
I've had this problem so here's what you
got to do you got to go in the in the
cache files and then you click on this
folder ok you see all this text right
here just delete it and there was like a
bunch of people like hey hey you you
know you have it this problem let me
show you how to solve it like I have a
secret potion for you every every video
I went to is like that until finally I I
started as a what should have been like
a one to two minute export ended up
being a 3 hours of messing around with
it followed by the next day having to
come back do uninstall the entire
Creative Suite reinstall it then it
worked this oh my gosh it would never
happen with avid media composer goes
serious so avid media composer like we
talked about this is you know an
industry standard but one of the reasons
it is a standard is because like
everything has to be in a specific
format and it runs off a specific
machine structure like it's not like oh
you can just use any PC with it it's
like no you have to it has to be built a
certain way in the video has to be a
certain type of video so they basically
went like we're not gonna try to support
everybody we're just gonna say eff you
unless you have the dollar signs to like
get this visitor Karger for it but of
course it's reliable because of that
definitely it does two things I think it
cuts you can cut a clip you can slide a
clip you can do lkl clip cuts to mange
cuts remember dude the whole alphabet of
cuts they're all there yeah and then
some well the other thing like you know
at least I would I would hope that for a
subscription model which everybody's
turning to these days like every free
app on like the App Store now is a
subscription
even if it's like the dumbest little
thing like I downloaded a decibel meter
and they wanted me to subscribe for
three dollars a month for like active
hearing protection which is always
running because you know they're just
trying to get you to sign up because you
hold you know in store DLC thing has
kind of died out so now the
subscriptions are the next big thing
that constantly know people for money
subscriptions for applications are the
stupidest things in the entire world
unless the application is on you
forgetting to use the application for
just one month yeah it's kind of it
sounds nice coming anytime you're gonna
buy like a one time use app and it tries
to make you subscribe they're just
telling you that like yeah they they
think you're an idiot and reality
capture you know I have to admit this to
you guys reality captures
subscription-based and the way you'll
first off canceling a subscription
through Steam you you get reality
capture through Steam you have to go
through like six levels of menus you
have to go to your like profile
and then you're within the six layer of
the menu take you OP subscribe they've
managed to ding us for about like an
extra three to four months because each
time I get it I'm using it the project
finishes usually the projects itself
takes a month so I finished a project
and then like it's already recurred
itself because I need to I have to get
them I have to get the subscription and
then cancel it mid project so to speak
for us to not get dinged even though you
only used it for like two days you know
and it's just I mean thankfully it's a
great program and it works but it's that
model of like Jesus Christ guys like
you're yes it feels like stealing I mean
you're basically paying for access to
the program for a little bit versus like
paying for access to the program
indefinitely by buying the software you
know and I get subscription models when
the program is actively keeping up with
you and that's I think that's the idea
behind Adobe is that like they're always
actively working on it new cameras are
constantly coming out this new formats
etc so they'll always be up to date with
you you'll never have to wait more than
a month or two but clearly that's not
the case
like so the Blackmagic Cinema Camera or
cameras I should say like the pocket the
new pocket that came out like
I saw all those cameras they are very
nice cameras in there kind of taking the
you know at least the indie side of like
digital cinema cameras taking that world
by storm
everybody's got a black magic pocket 4k
or 6k right now they're a wonderful
camera that came out you know last year
probably around this time and for the
longest time and I mentioned this early
in the podcast for a longest time it was
the number one feature request for Adobe
and they've implemented other codecs
super-quick some third-party After
Effects plug-in maker made a plugin for
using black magic rod natively in
Premiere and in After Effects and if a
third party person can do it and they
can do it within a couple weeks of you
know the camera being released and Adobe
can't do it 8 months 10 months after
being released it tells you that either
a Adobe's team is being very much
managed to put prioritize other things
that really don't aren't priorities of
their users or be they're actively
avoiding it because it's competition
because Blackmagic also makes DaVinci
Resolve which is a now a free editing
program and direct competitor it's a
very like solid conspiracy theory but
like big picture that would be really
really dumb if they're like oh you want
to use these new cameras that everyone
loves well you won't be able use
premiere the program you know and love--
program doing that force people to go
download the competition let me just
give you an example okay well let me let
me cap that let me just kept this a card
here cuz that is exactly what happened
over here we got the cameras we messed
with Premiere and it was it was not
going smoothly and we're just like screw
this let's switch over to resolve so
we've been editing all the videos now
and resolved because because I wasn't I
mean so like literally this feature
request caused us caused us to stop
using Premiere for a lot of videos now
yeah he says we still use from here for
the crew Channel and for the node
channel but all corridor videos edited
in DaVinci now yeah which is free by the
way
so so think about this let me just
couple notes there it's not a conspiracy
because that's probably exactly what
happened yeah and and the thing is I
don't know I don't mean to discredit the
the people that actually are working on
the software but at the top there's
people in that in that company that are
probably saying look they're a
competitor and so we're just not gonna
we're just not gonna include them
because that tech companies do that all
the time and if you want an apt example
I mean look at look at Apple or look at
General Motors you know that they like
neither those companies have done
anything over the course of time to like
adapt they're just like oh well you're a
competitor so we're just gonna continue
to yeah push away rather than to
integrate you and get all of your people
to work with our product exactly I think
at the end of the day unfortunately the
joke is still on us we're still paying
for the subscription
we're slaves because we're using After
Effects still we're still using audition
and in order to access that suite of
programs which premiere is included in
these we're still paying the same amount
so they haven't taken a loss because of
it other than you know the talk here so
to speak Joby's potion tastes of plums
and honey but no we can probably cut
back my one license but really whatever
I mean it is six hundred bucks and I
could say we can't cut back by one
license because they are gonna start
getting kicked out yeah there's only two
people paralyzed get me started on
Photoshop a little picture and it's like
loading for like it's like you open it
and it's like ten minutes of loading and
you're like alright and you bring your
picture in it's like slow and you like
click two buttons and you're like see it
lag and you're like I literally am
editing a 500 by 500 pixels jpg like
what is how I got one for ya
why doesn't Photoshop have thumbnail
previews yet why is it still just a PSD
icon oh yeah why just like cash a tiny
on max it doesn't put on pcs
notice it does max I'm dative it's an
operating system-level TST like readers
Wow Dobie if you don't make yourself
just talk to Microsoft come on like sit
down with them and like make it for them
if you got it like it would be like a
summit I'll give you root access to
every file on my hard drive and the
ability to change them yeah I'm gonna
share a screen with you guys that will
tell you exactly why Dobie hasn't done
these kind of features it's like how
many more Friday nights if you want to
grow is it a graph of their stock over
the last hours it is a graph of disabled
cheering but it's okay look I can
imagine how I was joking there their
stock here what's the day today
June 24th 2020 okay let's just go back a
few years let's go to oh I don't know
how about June of 2012 that's a long
time ago they go to like I want to just
go back to four years ago because they
started this four years ago four years
ago to date June 24th 2016 Adobe's stock
price was 98 dollars okay what's up now
do you want to guess what it is today
$120 what you guess two hundred and
twenty dollars four hundred and thirty
Wow
Jesus yeah that's a simple model man and
then wins the pandemic hit you know they
it was kind of going down it peaked in
February and it was kind of going down
but then BOOM March and it just took off
again because people are like I need
something to edit my videos so I can
become an influencer because I lost my
other job so now I'm gonna do this
that's why everyone's influencing each
other now we're all just influencing
each other yeah we're all just shouting
up brand deals we all have Squarespace
pages we're also telling each other it's
like I have a sparse basement you have a
Squarespace page but I recommend it
still I'll get an affiliation bonus it's
trade codes let's let's let's make a do
some racketeering boys all right let's
all swap referral codes yeah and then
and then they'll pay us two dollars more
person per integration because we we
scammed those extra subs okay to their
program love you Squarespace better than
all those other ones this video is
brought to you by Squarespace as well as
yeah we owe our CSS to them you know
we're gonna do for the next Squarespace
integration we're gonna I'm asking Gabe
to print shirts with with
squarespace.com slash quarter Queenie
the game shirt with every brand Jake
Jake need to be like a NASCAR style suit
that just says yeah everything oh man we
should do that this is what this is one
of the solutions to our Dobby problems
every time I try to put the title with
the coupon code in the timeline it
ditches out so we just put it on Jake's
shirt don't have to put the title in in
the guillotine channel ever comes back
you can put sponsors logos on the
guillotine
that's what we're thinking like
literally like a NASCAR like door panel
yeah I mean we need to get him like a
racing suit yes and just get the patches
man yes someday we'll get that back
let's do it man let's let's do it on the
court the next corridor bomber do the
patches you know and patches that's
really sewn on patches should also get
one of those temporary a printable
temporary tattoo kits so you can base
yes print out any design you want and
each time we're doing a brand
integration show that there's a new
tattoos it's good how much will you pay
me those things sometimes they mess up
though and they
permanent marks oh really I mean doesn't
get a real tattoo
get off later Jacob how much you charge
charge
real question how much yeah how much
would it cost to put a Squarespace logo
on your body with on your ass at some
point in the future but it happy do I
get to pick where it goes in the squeeze
as it go on Jake's arms on the arm it
doesn't go over your current tattoo it
can go can integrate it go anywhere on
my arm yeah give me a real number like
if I were to write you a check you back
alright and you can laser it off yeah in
two years if you want it two years hmm a
real number do you how big how big does
it have to be hmm three inches by three
inches that's very big yeah well you got
Syria I need to be readable yeah doesn't
have to be there money has to pay off or
can it be like are we talking about like
up here sure yeah
right there boom three by three inches
by three inches right there Squarespace
you could put in a part of an arrow
going that's a pretty significant tattoo
I don't know I know but yes it took us a
pretty significant numbers number but
this is a real like seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars yeah you know
right that sounds about right
I wouldn't probably do it for less than
that okay that's like okay well what if
the brand comes and says well our budget
was 500k yeah Ben the question is how
much and they're like take it or leave
it
anybody said but you can they get two by
two instead of three question I'd have
to negotiate down on the size a little
high for us how much does a laser
removal cost it's probably not bad like
tattoo black over it mmm so you have a
black square well actually you can make
the tattoo removal free if you then like
just get to a swastika over the hole
to go through a program of gang tattoo
removal you just go to expressvpn you
know and go hey guys what do you think
yeah gnarly skin yeah I've had a few
tattoos there it's but it's still prime
real estate prostitution start the
bidding war now all right space if
you're listening it's a fair price hit
us up like it's on Jake's body you know
and so on how is it like how do I I feel
bad it's like even though honey is it I
could just especially if I got the URL I
could just go ahead this guy's today's
video yeah you know I'm saying though
it's like it's I feel even though it
maybe be part of this business and the
whole thing like I I just don't know if
I could accept this portion of that
money and yeah you know what I mean it's
like I kind of cursed it be all yours
Jake it's all you would be hundreds I'm
you Jake I appreciate that guys I'll
build a room in a house just for you
guys as part of the receipt of the cash
just from wow dude you got like a
Chester mister get a guest room
no one else is allowed in there you guys
could decorate it however you want
oh well that's way better a triple bunk
like the kowloon walled city man well I
mean one of the things we say about
Dobby though is you know embrace the
[ __ ] mm-hmm
why I mean why are we embracing it there
must be something to Adobe's product
something that keeps us there something
that keeps us just clicking that open
mold follow button on those premier
projects yeah I mean because at their
core like they're very clean programs
they have a very like you know somebody
had to invent the nonlinear editing
interface it was a George Lucas but it's
friends but uh hey friends um but
specifically somebody had to invent the
nonlinear editing interface so it's just
some dude going like what if we had like
a horizontal line and the units of
measurement were frames and seconds and
like blocks represented the clip that
occupied that period of time and it was
like yeah that works in like no one else
has like tried something new except for
maybe iMovie since then and like that's
what Adobe does really well premiere
just has like it has that it's clean
like the good features that do work are
really good features that do work and
then it's like it's like there's a boat
and like the boat itself is solid and
there's a lot of things that have been
stuck to that boat like one of those
little like motors that you put the
front of your boat to like pull you
through like the weeds slowly and it was
like a depth finder but it doesn't work
and the battery's broken
trolling motor without a blade exactly
but the boat itself is still a decent
boat you know it gets he on the lake and
like yes like having a used car basic it
has a nice big paint job it's not loo
metric color paint job that new label
colors guys any color you want no any
company 20 guys
here's another example though of like
you know once again paying fifty times
six
so three hundred dollars a month that is
that's a lot of my it's like thirty
thousand that's three thousand six
hundred dollars a year or something like
that yeah
I mess up my maths I started thinking
about the point is gonna say either way
it's a lot of money it's thousands of
dollars so there's his color space I
talked about it before called the Aces
color space the Academy of Motion
Pictures the same people that have the
whole Oscars party those people came
together because they're like you know
what all our editors are Pro editors
here that are winning these awards are
like boy it sure is a pain in the butt
when I have four different cameras from
four different companies going into my
editing timeline and they all look
different
whereas back in the day I could just buy
one type of film and put it on my
cameras and they all looked the same and
so they got together like you know at
camera companies would you be down to
work with us on figuring out a solution
and pretty much all of them said yes and
they invented this color space that will
take any input camera setting and put it
into a unified color space that is
linear in other words like if something
is twice as bright the number is twice
as big it's a very straightforward easy
basic math kind of thing so it's easy to
program for and then you can transform
out of that color space into any display
so you can you know if you're gonna see
something on a TV screen or computer
screen or your phone you can output into
that color space which is called rec
seven or nine or you can output into
like a theater color space you can
output into you know an HDR TV color
space etc etc so you know you can pull
in all these new sources from all these
different cameras plop them into your
aces color space edit it and it looks
great on any system at any point you
don't have to match the colors between
the cameras anymore and it's really
useful and boy that sure sounds like
something that adobe would want when
they
that they advertise that you know their
systems support all the different types
of cameras right well this thing's been
out for like three years now and it's
still not present in Adobe Premiere its
present in DaVinci its present an avid I
believe but it's not in Premiere and
just sitting here paying money every
month for these features that are
essential for the job that we do and I
feel like once you get to like multiple
thousands of dollars a year like that's
the point where if if you're working
with the company you can call them up
and ask them to put somebody on the job
for like a day or two you know it's like
hey I'm giving you guys over three
thousand dollars a year could you send a
rep out for a day to fix this or make
this thing for us like most businesses
would start working with you at that
level but like these core tools which
you not only us but lots of people need
just aren't in the program and maybe
it's because Adobe decided to buy like
50 programs at once and then try to run
all of these maybe that's the issue
maybe it's that you know I don't know
but like I would rather that I'd like to
know that the program I use isn't
dependent on another program to either
have somebody working at it or not
working on it for my program to have
people working on it you know so it's a
tricky thing and like I mean the other
thing that really stands out to me
currently is like AI and machine
learning like you see you know two
minute papers is a YouTube channel that
watch all the time and like weekly
there's like a new thing coming out like
AI based motion interpolation lets it
get slow motion from stuff that wasn't
originally slow motion and it looks
wonderful ai based you know rotoscoping
where you can cut people out and it
works wonderfully AI based object
removal etc etc it's like these are
literally like students that are making
these things for free and this didn't
just start like a month ago that's been
going on or for years now and like even
this stuff is like not even in Adobe yet
like it's not in Premiere it's on actual
facts like DaVinci Resolve has an AI
based motion interpolation thing to give
you slow motion now but that doesn't
exist in Adobe and once again it's like
just hire these guys like you know take
literally my subscription that I pay you
guys and like maybe gather like three or
four other companies and pull that
together and hire a team of these people
to make plugins and I know there
$130 a month stock price though higher
some students and add-on to your program
yeah just make a point wait I don't care
if it's janky your programs already
janky there they're just there got to
comfortable man it's exactly what
happened with steam she was just like
well we invented this online way to
purchase video games and and then
literally for some unknown ungodly
reason all the Triple A game titles were
like we don't need that and then like 10
years into it they were like oh well
maybe we should do this and then they
finally started just as of like the last
few years releasing games on their own
platforms or on like different platforms
and not releasing am on Steam but for
the longest time steam just sat back and
collected their 30 percent and yeah even
all the entitled gamers who are like I
refuse to buy anything on the epic game
store and it's like wait are you trying
to support the monopoly here what's the
motive there isn't one yeah it just gave
dude gamers I I mean it's just I had to
save someone I have to get this off my
chest
uh-oh this is something that's been
brewing for about like three weeks and I
like told Sarah this and she's like I
don't are you so angry about this okay
so this is dumb but maybe it will make
you guys kicked off too a few weeks ago
Epic Games had a $10 coupon for like you
could apply to any games that were over
$14.99 doll you know $14.99 okay mm-hmm
any game over that price you could put
this $10 coupon on and get the game for
super cheap so the guys who make witcher
witcher 3
witcher 3 was out for $14.99 okay hmm
and when they saw the coupon they were
like let's make this 1498 so people
still paid in the game and then everyone
was like they are so greedy I can't get
this game for 498 or whatever you know
and they're like losing it they're like
these guys are evil what are they doing
and I like I was so angry I'm like
first off guys I've put like I played
the game for like 60 hours okay
let's break the cost down let's say you
paid for quote-unquote full-price 1490
that's not it you know $59.99 s full
price you're getting this for $14.99 you
want to break that [ __ ] down like you're
telling me you're getting ripped off
no no tell ripped off doing anything
else other than buying this game for
$14.99 yes for even like even a casual
playthrough that game it may be like 25
hours you know you want to divide that
by the $14.99 you pay you're paying down
$1 66 for the world class one of the
best video games ever created a dollar
66 per hour of world-class entertainment
it all right it's like what else imagine
imagine spending four 1498 to do to play
like laser tag with your buddies over
like 60 hours mock 66 and see how much
triple-a entertainment you can get the
street corner so angry somewhere well
it's cuz you respect the game and the
quality of the case yeah this games it's
just like okay Sony was got it off my
chest you feel better I feel a lot
better
Sam you're right you all right yeah well
that's what happens when you give an
entire generation of kids everything for
free and then they realize that the real
world doesn't function like that and
they get pissed and then they complain
about their video games and they knock
down a few statues and they burn down a
few buildings
very thin long thread the statue of link
that they pulled down the other day yeah
but we have been using da Vinci recently
you have I haven't done that yet yeah
you know because the the thing of like
it's like practicing one form of martial
arts and getting really good at it and
there's somebody coming up be like I
could beat you and you're like yeah and
then they beat you like oh I should
practice that form a little bit too if
you don't clunky and slow and like
sometimes it's nice to just go back and
do your Tai Chi or whatever it is like
touch he's not really martial arts but
you let air you get the analogy but it's
warmups it's warmups it'sit's slow
motion martial arts but it's like using
certain programs and your clunky when
you go to other programs I decide like
the order in which we participate so
yeah then she resolves cool - yeah it is
it's got its own levels of jank but
nothing that's you're redeemable yeah
and it's free and if you're just trying
to edit cool videos and make them look
nice and you're not getting too heavy
into visual effects you can basically do
everything in there resolve has some
jank too though there was something I
was trying to do in there the other day
and
incredibly simple and it should have
been like yeah existent and it just
wasn't and then you had to like I don't
again I had to go deep into the YouTube
and they were like you trying to do
something in DaVinci let me show you I
know the deepest secrets yeah no it's
not without its flaws but it considering
it's free it is certainly of I would say
its overall a better editing studios not
free and the studio versions only $300
though so even then that like that's
cheaper than a year of Adobe to be for
yourself and then on top of that result
has the sound program the sound
applicator light it's got his version of
After Effects but you shouldn't
unfortunately a little more complicated
than that's no base because it's no
based and sometimes that can f you up
but and then it has the color grading
suite which is the industry standard for
color grading like that's what movies
are color rated it yeah like time to
look up tails and premiere your footage
is just gonna stop it stops working why
did my footage stop Oh cuz you applied a
color lookup table what why yeah what
works like you shoot on like any camera
then isn't raw and you basically have
like six layers of adjustment layers of
look-up tables you have a conversion
lookup table that brings it from s logs
you know like Sony s log to rec 709 or
even Sony s log to like red log film or
like a standard log format and then you
have another one that converts a
standard log format to your f11 alright
and then you have an actual like primary
color grade and any of your second car
and they're all just done on these giant
tables of adjustment layers and each one
you add yearly cuts your playback speed
by like 10% so once you get over like
three or four you just can't watch a
project in real time anymore yeah versus
DaVinci Resolve which literally can just
have mismatched GPUs in your computer
and if you resolve will still utilize
all of them reduce computations imagine
that imagine imagine a world see here's
the thing now is the point when devs
whether for Adobe or da Vinci or avid
this really should be like all right
cool
we've been using the same style editing
for
two decades now we've all used it enough
how would you actually want to use some
of these programs well it'd be your
ideal situation to sit down and start
editing and like da Vinci has some of
that where its flow is a little bit
different and its layout is a little bit
different and like the way you're
supposed to work through a time line is
a little more focused it's not trying to
support Genki like grandma's editing you
know techniques versus like the new
slick like fourteen-year-old editing
techniques like you know the Vinci's a
little more like you should edit it like
this and we're not really going to give
you the tools to edit it in a slower way
just because that's how you learn to do
it whereas premiere is like you can edit
it however you have learned to you do
editing um anyways like this is the
point which like people need to step
back and kind of reappropriation perhaps
talk about editing programs man every
day so guys if you want to get in on
deep software programs next time we're
gonna be talking about just After
Effects comps we're even gonna get in a
Photoshop comp sesh with people mm-hmm
it's gonna come in for cinema 4d next
week and it's just gonna be Clint a
microphone and his thoughts and then I
would really love to follow the chance
with an episode entirely about Adobe
Media encoder yes talking about some
cool codecs and problems with that do
you think they like went back in time
and like history so that like you I
wasn't a thing before they designed that
like they just forgot everything they
know about before times and they brought
them in to design the UI actual chaotic
spreadsheets one for took the lines off
the spreadsheet but they still stayed
where they should be
we're totally joking we're never gonna
return this subject ever again
none of these things will make it into
future episodes so it's good enough in
you can be assured that when you click
on this next podcast you will get pure
entertainment no education no gripes
against software nothing of boring but
just that ripe meaty content you know
and love on the court or cast export you
know we're doing right now in this
episode we're seeing who the truest of
the truest of them I had a good chuckle
I saw a Christian knife in the car we
had too much chuckles but the best
chuckles we only laugh so we don't cry
only listeners you hear your laughter
there's its tears as well some laugh
tracks for the audio only folks hear
tracks yeah tune in next week when you
complain about the ending of Game of
Thrones yeah we're not doing that either
I'm gonna go edit some more in adobe
after this podcast yeah Nick's gotta get
back to anyone premiere well we well
we're talking about it and let us know
in the comments what you guys want to
see I'm trying to get Bret the sun dried
Iran but uh can we go this week he was
busy he's got a gig guys gotta go to the
writing gig and he said that he's
working from home he's writing every day
and he doesn't he's not sure where the
time-space continuum ends because he's
just been writing and but come on the
thumbnail for that podcast is be so
great we got to do like Teletubbies
where there's Teletubbies is Nick and
Clinton Teletubbies and then Brett's
smiling faces in the sky in the song
alright I got one more thing anybody
listening who happens to be from Adobe
if you've actually listened to the
podcast as far just know that we're just
wishing for the best we support you guys
there are a lot of great things in the
program
that's but there's also some hiccups and
I think we can be open about problems
that we have with the software and we
hope that you guys get the support that
you need to continue in making it
awesome because it's a lots and lots of
artists depend on you to do so yeah
please get the politics out of the
software support that black magic stuff
support the artists and hey I want my 50
bucks a month to go do something good
that's all I got No
cool yeah alrighty Doby till next time
hey boys see you guys in the next
podcast subscribe subscribe